i called it a side project where i was
dabbling in app creation and i created
an iphone app called scan that would
scan barcodes flash forward i ended up
selling that app to snapchat and it was
a really really crazy busy time in my
life where i was like hustling working
on that app i'd like raise money from
investors for it i was playing soccer
kind of going to school um and so from
like super crazy and then when we sold
it it gave us all of a sudden just
ultimate freedom of lifestyle
financial freedom and freedom of time
and so it was this big question of like
what do we want to do next in our lives
and it was actually jessica's idea to
do a little bit of traveling
a little bit
[Music]
that was justin garrett who are travel
journalists that have essentially built
an empire called the bucket list family
years ago they set out on a journey to
learn to find happiness with less live a
life of compassion and service and to
create lifelong memories together and
they did this by selling all of their
belongings traveling around the world
and documenting it online back when
garrett sold his iphone app to snapchat
they came to a position of what should
we do next so in 2015 is when they
decided to set on their journey together
and
they took three years living full-time
on the road which is just astounding to
me and incredibly um just inspiring and
hard for me to comprehend but they did
that and they have traveled to 80
countries together now in this episode
we have a wonderful conversation and
talk about all the things in regards to
if they ever get burned out from so much
that they do and from traveling so much
what their education is like for their
children being on the road and traveling
how traveling has been since covet even
and what gives them purpose and what
helps them keep going and get inspired
through all that they do and all the
innovation and creativity that they have
in their lives so i really hope that you
enjoy this episode we get into a lot of
fun things including like social media
for children and
just a lot more so i really hope you
enjoy this episode let's get started all
right thank you guys so much for coming
on the podcast i am so excited to have
you here and i've been really looking
forward to this conversation we have too
uh you said maybe like a year and a half
almost two years ago we were in our gym
and you're like i just i want to do
something new i want to do something
more like
that just like
really stretches me and you're like i'm
gonna do a podcast now yeah and you're
doing it i know and now it's here now
it's here i know right like we would
like bounce ideas off each other talk
about all the things that we're going
towards and it's always so fun to
connect with you guys because we're kind
of in the same realm of what we do
and you guys inspire me so much because
you're such go-getters and like amazed
at how every time there's some new thing
you're doing i'm like what
how in the world
where did you get this idea like just so
creative so like just such go-getters
and it's really inspiring and i know
that's part of reason why you guys are
so successful because people look at you
guys and are like
whoa they're different they're doing
something way different than most people
are doing
i think that's an important thing and
just the world of social media is i
think the downside of it is social media
like kind of funnels people into doing
being the same person and all trying to
like compete with each other and so it's
a beautiful thing when you just like
take a left turn when everyone else is
going right and set yourself apart like
that's where you find the success right
totally i mean you guys are like
trendsetters essentially there's a lot
that you've done that inspires so many
honestly you say all this and
i just look at him i'm like
he's the one and i'm like i'm i'm the
support i'm the cheerleader and i kind
of go where he goes
but he's the one who's like reaching for
the stars and then i like help him get
there right i was actually going to ask
that like who's what like i think people
would want to know like who does what
job what role who's the ambitious
creative one who's the one that's like
let's like calm it down let's do the
business side
those words have ever left my mouth i am
the queen of moderation right and
garrett is the king of extreme yeah it's
pretty pretty accurate what's it like
being married to garrett it's so hard
i will say like my life is somewhere
completely
like i never in my wildest dreams would
have ever been like i'm gonna have a
travel around the world and have a house
on the beach in hawaii like that wasn't
even like remotely on my radar
um right so garrett's always the one
who's like pushing for more looking for
more what else is out there how can we
be different how can you know like
garrett doesn't want to be mainstream at
all right
i mean yeah oh yeah
i might not be to the level that you are
but i definitely have that sense inside
of me for sure and andrew andrew is more
like you like okay let's just calm it
down we got a good thing going we just
keep it the way it is and i'm like no
this is no let's i want to do this i'm
excited about this because i'll because
when i came to him about the podcast i
was like babe i really want to start a
podcast and he's like i don't know
you gotta go you got a good thing
yeah he's like you got it going why
don't you just keep doing this i'm like
no i'm like i'm really ready to talk
about things and get really in-depth on
things and a podcast would be the place
to be and he was very like skeptical at
first totally like supportive but like
let's just slow it down i'm like okay i
got about obviously let's think about it
right yeah yeah exactly and while i am
i'm not quick to jump to things i still
was like this is this is the thing we
need to do this and he's like i don't
know i don't know like it took a little
while to get it on board all right so
you guys are so busy in your life i mean
we love to hang out and we hang out hung
out here and there but i think i would
enjoy hanging out with you guys more but
we're just both so busy
hanging out with friends that much i
know like we kind of did when we first
moved here and now it's like like
scheduling like getting us all girls
together like it's difficult it's a lot
of work partially that was one of my
favorite things when everyone else had
like a million reasons to complain about
the year of 2020 one of the silver
linings that i really appreciated is
like everyone's lives slowed down in my
opinion in a beautiful way that forced
them to like reevaluate their lives
reevaluate how they spend their time and
their priorities and
it might just be the optimist in me but
it was a very special time for like my
life to like recalibrate totally
absolutely i mean there's definitely a
silver line to everything and that was
definitely it for sure everything slowed
down on the island completely
so that's kind of the nice thing about
like you know you're good friends and
you guys are creators and and we are too
and so when we finally get together
there's no like where have you been it's
like no we know you've been working you
know we've been hustling and so there's
that like common thread totally and how
was it different for you guys being
travel journalists like when covet
happened
honestly it was just what we needed like
garrett will never like we already said
we'll never ever ever slow down it
literally took a global pandemic for him
to be like oh okay and
i had a hard time emotionally last year
but at the end of the day i feel like it
was really good for our family because
it showed garrett i mean like we had a
few friends here and there but we
weren't we didn't feel part of the
community and it wasn't until coveted
and everyone was just here and it was
just us on the island that we were like
oh like i feel like i have neighbors
garrett fell in love with surfing like
in that aspect it's what we needed but
now it's good and bad because now like
we have
yeah it's like do you want to travel do
you want to be home and honestly i want
to do both and it's really hard to pick
and choose like
when we go when we go
well
what's the difference now right now with
sense everything that's happened for
going getting back into traveling i
would say there's some good and some bad
the good about traveling currently is
you can go to some unique places that
might
usually on a typical year be very
crowded and they're like empty and it's
a special time to experience those
places because of how empty they are the
downside is it's just way more like
logistically nice
but also like i really appreciate how
right now people who want to travel are
much more conscious
travelers they're super mindful and like
they've saved up and they've been locked
in doors and so now people are like when
i'm going somewhere i'm gonna like
really like do it mindfully right and
that's been really nice to see that i
feel like people aren't being so like
frivolous with their travels
um
i i think that might change but you know
at least the last year in the little bit
that we have traveled we just spent the
last three four months in africa and um
everybody out there was so happy to see
us like so grateful to have oh such a
special feeling
when we would visit a lodge and like the
village would come out and be like we
haven't had visitors in so long they're
so excited i mean for most those places
their livelihood depends completely i
know and so that was that was really fun
to be going around africa and experience
that over and over yeah i mean that's
something a lot of people didn't even
talk about at all like what happens to
all these livelihoods that they worked
really hard to build
yeah right for sure so when you're out
there you're
you're super grateful and you're super
mindful of these people and what they've
gone through and you know hearing other
people's experiences in these african
villages and these
these um safari guides who haven't
worked you know and so you try to be as
generous as you possibly can because you
know they've like really been through it
you know
right well for people who don't know you
guys who maybe you might be watching i
mean i know a lot of people know who you
guys are but for people who don't know
can you tell a little bit about how you
got started to becoming travel
journalists and like essentially
becoming the bucket list family
you take this one babe this storm of a
lifestyle start so
when i was
we were in college together in utah
and jessica was what did the kids call
it a sugar mama
she was working and i was not i was
playing soccer and then on the side i
had like
i called it a side project where i was
dabbling in app creation and i created
an iphone app called scan that would
scan barcodes flash forward i ended up
selling that app to snapchat and it was
really really crazy busy time in my life
where i was like hustling working on
that app i had like raised money from
investors for it i was playing soccer
kind of going to school um and so from
like super crazy and then when we sold
it it gave us all of a sudden just
ultimate freedom of lifestyle financial
freedom and freedom of time and so it
was this big question of like what do we
want to do next in our lives and it was
actually jessica's idea to
do a little bit of traveling
a little bit
like i wanted to go to australia i
wanted to go to the lantern festival in
thailand geared one and go to tonga so
you're like sweet let's do a couple
months four months i think we'd like
four or five months planned but i really
appreciated jessica's mindset because it
was because we don't know what we want
to do next in our lives like what is the
next chapter we don't feel old enough to
like settle down or like retire
what do we want next jessica's mindset
was perhaps by traveling we can see how
different cultures kind of like find joy
and happiness and fulfillment learn from
them and then make this big life
decision but this is also where you see
like my ma
moderation and garrett's like extreme
mentality just to like i'm like let's do
a little bit of traveling and gareth's
like we will sell everything and we will
share with the world yeah it's like you
don't just take this one little you're
like i haven't a little idea and he's
like i'm gonna make it into an empire
i'm going to create something fantastic
with this idea and garrett like garrett
is an avid journal keeper has been since
i met him back in russia
13 years ago and so i know he and he
would have documented our travels
regardless and stuff but you know then
with instagram and youtube he kind of it
was mostly for us also a little bit for
our friends and family we were leaving
behind and then um but i do i do think
he was that was at like the forefront of
like influencers and travel influencers
back in 2015 and
um
you know we kind of got on board our
timing was impeccable and our story was
good you know so now when people are
like i'm gonna do what you're doing i'm
like
one thing i'm super grateful for
and i think you do this really well is
because we got started on social media
with i think um a wholesome like proper
uh mentality like intentions of i want
to create this content to forever
remember
remember these like yes moments and
experiences with my family uh now we
have this content whether or not it blew
up or became popular or you know became
a successful youtube channel
these are videos that we treasure and
cherish and like
again it had nothing to do with like
views and likes and all of that for sure
so i you know i watch your content it's
the same thing where i'm like man
they're going to forever treasure like
these memories and this content i like
and you do a good job i would say ours
is very good in that we share wholesome
content and memories you do a really
good job of doing that and putting like
good quality information on thank you
that i think is like evergreen because
you put so much effort into what you do
that anyways it just makes me really
happy and that's why i wanted to talk
about it because more and more you're
seeing the opposite on it where when i
see people creating mindless content
it's like yeah you're getting the clicks
and the likes but like
i just hope you're proud of this in like
10 years which is also cool to see that
ellen is like i mean it's this is a
perfect example of being like okay like
we've done the youtube thing like what
else can we do to like push the limits
and like just put better stuff out there
because at the end of the day you know
like you've shared
what you know
and what you've learned and now it's
like what else can i learn so now you're
sitting here talking to other people
anyway it's really awesome that you're
doing this that's that's for sure i'm
like so in line with what you just said
because when i started my instagram and
the youtube channel i was really just
like sharing my life sharing the healthy
fresh fruits and vegetables i was eating
what i was feeding my kid elvis and just
our life and living simply and wanting
to grow our own food and it just started
to grow i mean this was back before like
social media was really oversaturated
and it just i'm like whoa what's
happening like i didn't even realize
like it just completely was not on my
radar and as it was growing it's like oh
i can do something with it okay people
are asking for my recipes people want to
know how to eat plant-based and then i
made one youtube video and i said this
who did i say this too i look back now
and i had no idea when i made my first
youtube video that that amount of views
was like a big deal like i was just like
cool i put out a video like i didn't
yeah i didn't even realize at all like
now if you try to put out a video it's
like you know just you have to work so
hard to get every single yeah and i
think my first video had like a hundred
thousand views or something and i was
just like cool like i didn't even this
is so funny how i didn't even realize
that at all and it really just the
intentions behind just sharing
sharing just you know authentically
memories because i i s i'm so with you
my kids are gonna look back at these
videos they already do they already
watch their birthday party videos and
they're like oh let's watch it again
like scott wants to watch her home
birthing video when she was born all the
time imagine imagine when she's like 40
years old and gets to see that like how
it's a gift i actually think that i'm
this is just a theory but i feel like
our children are going to like have
heightened memories of their life
because they get to replay it over and
over again whereas like when i think
about my childhood like how many
memories do i actually have it's like a
handful and it's like in a blur and you
remember the ones that are on video
camera but like very little and so just
thinking about how many your kids are
going to remember from all their travels
is amazing see when i see people out
there a similar thing happened so i
worked at snapchat for some time right
and when i saw like the inner workings
of snapchat and we would see what type
of people what type of content people
were creating on snapchat knowing that
it was going to disappear every 24 hours
people started
just creating garbage and like there's a
lot of negative that can come from
instagram but you know the whole
mentality of like instagram's a
highlight reel
again positive and negative one of the
positives is it encourages people to
live a more
i don't want to say impressive but a
more meaningful life right yeah because
they want to like make they want to
share it and they want to share it and
like people say like do it for the gram
and on one hand you're like that's
annoying they're doing it for something
else but at least they're doing it you
know right at least they're getting out
and like totally living a life worth
documenting i'm telling you when i saw
the inner workings of snapchat and how
people who knew they were like not going
to remember anything the very next day
they were doing the opposite in the
right life like they're not proud of um
and i see a
uh some of that with what's going on on
tick-tock and i just hope people will
like not have any regrets and create
content that they're not proud of rather
than just chasing trends especially
children and teenagers because their
brains are still developing i actually
want to do an entire episode on like
social media and children and how just
think back just to imagine our lives in
high school right now if we had an in
junior high if we had social media and
everyone had like a like selfie like
their own pages oh my gosh and now
there's like i really don't like the
face favorites are the ones of people
being like me as a 13 year old girl
making a dance video versus like 13 year
old girls now like those are hilarious
die yeah those are really funny i
i think you should do that episode and
i'm really curious who you can find
because you want to find someone right
who's the side of the conversation who
thinks kids should spend time yeah
social media
yes i'd be very curious if you want
someone who's against it i'm your guest
i know oh i am so i'm very like okay
guys can i get all my friends on board
can we all just not introduce
smartphones until like 18.
like garrett's nephew called him like
recently and was like can you can you
convince my mom to help me get an iphone
and gary was like you called the wrong
wrong guy
put your mom on the phone i'll talk some
sense into her and i was like to my
sister i was like hey i spend all day
every day on social media so much of the
goodness in my life has come from social
media and i will still tell you do not
let that boy have no way oh my gosh
there's you already are so at such an
insecure stage of your life and it's
it's hard enough as it is let alone
having putting your life out there and
honestly face filters do such a
disservice to humanity in my opinion and
the way that it's just i'm sensing your
feeling on your own board with me on
this like the way that it completely
changes people's perception of what
reality is to a point where you're
showing the whole world that this is
what you look like when really you don't
look like that and then we literally
yesterday had a girl apply for a job and
we were like oh you know like how cute
is she it was like some stories and then
we looked at her profile and we're like
that's a different person yeah two
different people it was crazy yeah i
couldn't believe it yeah it's it's
actually astounding and like even i
think people have good intentions and
don't really i think most people don't
really see the harmony right i think
you're right yes and i think you're not
trying to and also it's easier to not
put yourself out there that like and
show all your flaws and your wrinkles
and things like that because it's easy
because you know people criticize people
are so quick to criticize so i
understand why people do it um but i
just think with children yeah it's fast
i think there's a balance like you want
to teach children the benefits of all
that you can learn about while being
online and having access to the internet
and just like there's there's a lot of
interesting and important things about
that but giving children full access to
like a smartphone where they i mean this
is heading a totally different
conversation
but giving them full access to that and
like there's so much danger involved
with that but anyways i i do agree
completely with like everything you said
about
the intentions behind on youtube and
views and how easy it is for people to
like move to a place where they're
posting content that they might regret
down the line because of the views and
there's so much of that actually and
that's one reason why i think people
love you so much because you're honestly
putting out super amazing content that's
quality it's inspiring people children
learn so much from your videos by seeing
all your travels and the service work
that you guys do so
i think that's why you guys are so
successful because you aren't doing that
we'll see even on the topic of kids on
social media because and we're almost
like hypocrites trying to do both where
when our kids were born we started an
instagram page for each of them so that
we could post a photo a day as a journal
of like hey here's your life when they
get older um but not you know i think
they have like 300 000 followers on
those like pages and so yeah it's
it's a weird thing for sure i understand
yeah because there might be someone
listening and being like well hey you
put your kids online so like what's the
difference right but i i do think
there's a big difference but what are
your thoughts but i think it's that i
think it's your intentions and our
intentions is uh are that we want to
put out goodness in the world um but
also just it's for the our kids to have
those memories so we'll see well and i
think you have to be like super
conscious of like how you shape it to
your kids how you like i mean i think
there would be no greater gift than when
dorothy's 16 years old to be like you
have this platform
that you could go and use and you could
change the world and you could show
other 16 year old girls like the life
you're living in the active healthy
lifestyle the family so that hopefully
at 16 you're still living we have some
friends who are
really big on social media they're 18
year old girls and they do just that and
it's amazing and then you've seen some
other 18 year old girls who've grown up
on youtube and have gone the other way
and so it's just kind of like
i mean it comes down to how it comes
down to who they are and what you know
what they can do with it but i mean i
still think like even like our kids
we try to never give them like ipads and
phones and stuff but dorothy sometimes
loves making movies and to me i'm like i
want my kids to be creators i don't want
them to be consumers
i don't want them to see what's on tick
tock and go do that trend i want them to
come up with their own trend and then
they can watch their own tick tock video
you know like go create and not like
more power to you like yeah do
make those memories and create and
create and create but just just stay
away from the consumption and then they
get to take with it or leave it like it
looks like hey take it or leave it you
can do what you want if you don't want
to do that yeah that's interesting
that's that i've never thought of it
that way because i know that that's what
you guys do they have their own channel
and everything like that
so as of now our kids are quite like
unaware of what social media is and how
it works uh at soccer practice a little
boy came up to dorothy and i was like
i love your instagram i love your
youtube and you could see it she's like
i don't really know what you're talking
about like you know and i appreciated it
so uh but that's something we will be
navigating over the next few years when
like they do become when they realize
like what that means and
you know dorothy came home from school
one day i think a year ago being like
how many followers do we have i'm like
i was like how do you know what i was
like and asked who chatter
do you guys get criticism sometimes
about like having your kids online
no not really no and and maybe it's
because we've been pretty vocal about it
like
um
me earlier on i had a really really hard
time putting ourselves out there like
when we left our travels our kids had
their instagram accounts and they're
they're private and i told garrett i was
like i'm not putting my kids out there
you hear those horror stories
and then i've kind of learned over time
you know garrett kind of helping me get
myself out there and get outside my
comfort zone the good that has come from
putting ourselves and our family out
there far
exceeds yes i totally minor criticism
that you get which
really hurts sometimes it really hurts
don't get me wrong oh for sure
you know
but because of what we've been able to
do and share i mean i i truly think
we've we've changed lives and you know
we've been a really good
light out in the world and i always say
i'm like
look for the most part people are on
social media you can put out good bad or
nothing and i think we should put out
good
i think being the light is what we need
instead of more darkness or instead of
nothing you know like let's just
let's just flood
social media with good with families
with health with like service like
that's that's like all we can do you
know yeah i mean there's always going to
be people who disagree with how you do
things but at the end of the day you
have to do with what you feel is right
for your family and it's best for you
and the world and everything like that i
sometimes get people asking me to show
more like quote-unquote real moments of
like my kids having tantrums or
something like that
and i it's bizarre to me because i'm
like i really care about like showing
all the respectful moments like i'm only
going to film my children when they want
to be filmed yeah and when you're
disciplining first of all your cameras
no not in your hair oh you're crying
[Music]
because i think we've had certain times
like that where like we've like filmed
cali like melting down on the floor and
people are like why aren't you helping
your child
but then if you don't show it you can
you can appease everybody i know yeah
yeah but i feel like i i feel like it's
important to be like explain that like
listen
i'm normal like everybody else like we
all have our hard moments i'm just
sharing what is respectful what my kids
would be happy to have online because my
kid elvis does understand insanity i
feel like do they do understand that
like we're online and the youtube yeah
maybe not to the full but like they
enjoy it and when they if they don't
feel like being on on screen like i do
not film them like you know it's just
whatever they want to be on they pretty
much just pop in when they want to be
essentially and the younger ones that's
obviously a little bit different but
okay to bring it back a little bit i
want to talk a little bit about your
scan app like what inspired you to even
create the scan app
i wish i could say it was a really good
idea
and but the truth is in my like journal
i had a list of
brilliant app ideas that i wanted to
create but i didn't have any experience
in the space of app creation so i was
like okay so of all my ideas here this
is the
dumbest lamest idea easiest i'm gonna
start there to teach myself how to
create the app and then i'll work my way
to the other ideas and that dumb lame
idea of creating a barcode scanner
blew up
so what made it why did you think it was
a dumb idea well it's just a barcode
it's just it's just basically
he like he learned i remember the day
you like we learned what a qr code was
and we were both like pretty hyped on
the technology we're like wow this is
like a really endless
like
technology that you could do so much
with so he was excited about that and
then you kind of just even looked at the
apps and you're like these are ugly
these are slow it's a super simple
solution
i work in my core i'm more less than a
coder i'm more of a designer designer
yeah as a designer i was like i could
create something that's just better
faster more simplistic than everything
that's out there and i mean like uh ebay
had an app out there i think google had
a scanning app out there and again like
they're just working well yeah when
you're gonna be like yeah i'm gonna go
compete against ebay scanner but i mean
that's kind of and so we were in the
media a lot because here comes this like
college kid freshman creates this app
and all of a sudden it's like
outperforming all like the big you know
corporations and their apps and there
was a time where we were i remember i
was going to san francisco to meet with
the creators of angry birds to see if
they wanted to invest in my app
and the day we flew out there
angry birds was the number nine app in
the app store and my app was the number
10. so i took a screenshot so i could
like show them like hey we're like
neighbors in the app store like in the
entire app store ranking like we were
top 10
and so the meeting is happening i was
like i want to show you guys something i
pull up the app store and during that
meeting we had switched so we were now
the number nine and they were the number
10. i was like i don't know if i should
show you guys this
but um it just was going crazy i mean
when those were kind of like the glory
days of the app store where we were
pulling in like 80 to 100 000 downloads
a day wow into this app and it was it
was going crazy um
and so yeah we we built the app for
three years amassed over 100 million
downloads and then sold it
that's amazing and i know i watched your
youtube videos you had two parts where
you explained the whole story of how you
sell your apps the acquisition madness
that was so amazing it was a really
incredible story crazy really crazy
story so for those who don't know he
sold his
his app for 54 million dollars and the
the thing is though like i really want
to know when you said at the end you're
like okay what are we gonna do we're not
just gonna retire why not just retire
and like live simply is there something
like within you like what is it because
i think some people might be like wait
why not just relax a little bit i will
say i do feel like i'm fortunate in my
life to have a lot of examples of people
who had
that much money or more money that were
very unhappy and i
was able to learn from those examples
and be like look i don't want to follow
in their footsteps
i saw money wreck a lot of people and so
we decided together
that we would either
just be so careful mindful of this money
or
pretend like it didn't exist until we
were at a point in our lives that we
could like maturely like
um react to this money and so one thing
that we're super proud of with what
we've created as like the bucket list
family is when we sold everything and
left our home the reason why we did sell
everything is because for the money from
the acquisition we put that aside and
promised ourselves we wouldn't just like
blow it traveling so we put that aside
and promise not to touch it except for
like service or non-profit
opportunities and so
everything that we created from the
bucket list family came from
45 000 that we got from selling all of
our belongings and so uh and started
from there you know that's incredible
we never touched the acquisition money i
think that's a really important part of
your story because a lot of people might
be inspired by you and they go oh well
they had so much money that's why they
got to do it but you chose to do
something really special and unique by
not spending it which is rare because
honestly there's like
really
famous people people who make a ton of
money and you can blow it all you
totally can or you can be financially
responsible and handle it in a different
way and you guys even not even just
handled it responsibly you like took it
to a whole another level where you're
like we're not even going to touch it
like that's really inspiring i think to
garrett and and we chat about this often
he's
you know he hasn't made the most amount
of money you've ever seen but like and
he hasn't been like insanely like famous
or whatever but something he's so proud
of and we're so proud of is
in the success we've had like even with
scan
he worked from home he saw me and
dorothy every single day he played
college soccer while building this like
big app like his
lifestyle like
balance was
for what we got out of scan was just
amazing and i mean it's the same thing
even now like garrett
really prides himself as a father like
most fathers don't get to spend all day
every day with their kids you know
and um
to be able to have created this
lifestyle as a dad
to get it be able to spend all the time
he wants with his kids and travel the
world with them he'll have people like
old investors or old like business
buddies be like so when are you going to
get back to it gareth's like are you
kidding me like i travel i get paid to
travel around the world with my family
like
what am i getting back to you know like
right he's created a lifestyle that i
know he's super duper proud of and like
he's worked really hard for it but he
he'll never ever sacrifice health family
friends
from for money and then on top of it
purpose and actually absolutely i don't
know if you guys know what the blue
zones are do you know what they are
they're like the longest living
civilization oh yeah in the world they
have the most centurions and they all
have like nine common characteristics in
why they ended up living so long and one
of them is purpose like they all had
even like well into their old age had
purpose they were with community they um
they weren't put into like um [ __ ]
like homes great they always had their
community always had purpose and drive
see i almost like hesitate to explain
this because it sounds kind of
psycho but um when when the acquisition
happened
we you know put it in the bank account
we connected with like financial
advisors all of that and since that day
i haven't checked our bank account
because i know if i saw
the money in there because i'm just a
human i would be very tempted to like
retire turn off
and like coast the rest of my life but
knowing how much i depend on purpose and
how much joy like that brings to my life
like literally garrett doesn't carry a
wallet he doesn't have i carry his
wallet and he is uh like
millions of dollars either plus or minus
where he thinks we are at like he has no
idea how much money we have but because
i know mentally what that would do to me
and i want to stay like young and hustle
and you know yeah and go out life with
purpose and so yeah it's a weird thing
but that's kind of where we're at that's
really interesting and inspiring so how
are you guys raised like i think a lot
of people might be like well were they
raised in a different way what made them
the way that they are
both of you
i was raised in the most like
stereo like i'm like the american girl
next door like 100 that was me
you were i feel like kind of the same
but your parents split at a young age
and um
i do think like you even took a byu like
a entrepreneurship class where they told
you like these are kind of some of the
things that make for a really good
entrepreneur but it went as far as like
your mom's a second like you're a second
generation immigrant you're like you
don't sleep well like they're all these
things like that garrett kind of fits
the bill for just like a super
successful entrepreneur
um but we we did um
we did both grow up like comfortably
with money definitely upper middle class
for both of us yeah but we both had
parents that didn't help us at all
financially once once we hit college
like yeah that was done so that was an
interesting part to it
i'm not sure like how it played a role
but we both grew up that way
and what examples is your parents set
for you guys
when i speak of people who had money and
no longer do
my parents are very
good bad examples of that um so that
that was ingrained in me of money will
not bring you happiness money can solve
problems and if you treat it
i mean i think in those youtube videos
on our channel where i explained the
acquisition i explained that
a legal part to the acquisition is that
i wasn't allowed to disclose that the
acquisition even happened and so there i
was having sold my company for 54
million dollars as a college student and
legally i could not tell my parents my
family my friends like anything so we
just told our family we were like
garrett's company's partnering with the
company out in l.a we're moving to l.a
and like legally we had no choice
and it wasn't it wasn't until crazy
story but it wasn't until north korea
hacked the company's emails and it was
all leaked out to journalists and this
like story went out in the wall street
journal
explaining snapchat acquired this utah
company for 54 million dollars from
garrett g and all of a sudden my family
and my friends are texting me like wait
what you know and that's how it all like
spilled out it was crazy so why didn't
they want you to tell anyone they were
just a super like confidential company
you know how out like kind of apple and
something they just a lot of tech
companies will do right it's all secret
yeah they don't you know how much they
spent which we were we were at the time
we were super grateful for it we didn't
want anybody to treat us differently we
just wanted to you know do our thing um
do you feel like people do treat you
differently now not everyone knows i
would say we've been lucky and fortunate
that 99 of people in our lives treat us
same old same old and hopefully we've
not changed ourselves who we are um but
you know there's been some unfortunate
cases of some people like definitely
treating us different because right well
i think anyone who has met you guys will
say that you are just as genuine and
kind as you come across online like it
i've talked spoken to people be like oh
you know them i'm like oh my gosh
they're like the nicest people they
really you guys really are as nice as as
you come across online which i don't
know if it's always the case for a lot
of people but for for you guys it's for
sure
for sure so we already talked about the
roles in your business and
well actually we didn't really get into
it we started to started a dabble but
like you're the dreamer are you the
business side you kind of like i do
everything else like literally gyarados
like this like the editing the
photography videography creative
creative and i'm literally
12 000 other things
so that's like the business
yeah so i
plan the travel i do the brand deals i
feed the children i do the laundry i
take out the trash i fix the garbage
disposal like i do all of the things
um which
yeah it's a
it's a lot but it's kind of just the way
we work and i think everybody has
different you know way their marriages
work and this is kind of what's
worked for us i mean our family is
completely not traditional as well
because i'm the same i'm like the
garrett i'm doing all the photography
and the videography and that takes a lot
of time like a lot of people might not
realize that i actually sometimes get
messages of people being like what do
you do for a living i'm like really
but also i think i'm sure andrew would
understand like there is a way to you
know where you have to learn how to work
with creatives and kind of give them
their space and let them do their thing
um
and that and see them in environments
that like thrive like and
i'm sure andrew would agree that like
you learned have to give and give so
that they can have their space and
there's you're all so much more happy
and successful because of it it's super
annoying but that's just kind of well
and i'm going to vent to fell creative
it's a tough thing when when what you do
like nobody else can do like nobody can
like yeah
that comes across as the most like
pretentious dumb thing to say but if
like
jessica's like hey
like do this for me and it's like
i okay but like what i'm doing you can't
do that for me like it's a tough thing
and yet in a marriage you want to just
be able to like help each other in both
ways
yes no i mean i definitely have times
where andrew be like ellen why are you
working so long on this like it's fine
just put it out there i'm like no it's
not done and he'd be like it looks fine
to me i'm like you don't understand like
like i can't just put something out
there i'm not proud of and and he'll on
his level be like it looks great babe
what are you worried about and i'm like
no like you really don't understand i
need like four more hours you know he's
like four more hours like are you
serious right now so for sure for sure
andrew like does all of our emails and
he does all the you know similar type
with you jessica
with the kids and stuff i'll hop in and
do some homeschooling with them but
andrea does most of it oh we should talk
about schooling what is education like
for your kids
education gosh that's the topic of
discussion at our fan in our family
right now discussion argument needed
discussion
yeah
i think too like we both grew up at the
super like traditional school and that's
kind of i think what we always pictured
and in hawaii and now particularly
during a pandemic it's just kind of all
out the window so we're kind of now like
really me in particular garrett wanted
to homeschool starting last year
and um anyway our kids are in a private
school right now and i'm just happy
they're in school but at the same time
like it's not what it should be and now
we're we're close to pulling them oh
it's so difficult i think a lot of
people are actually pulling their kids
out of school right now a lot of
teachers are actually sometimes quitting
even and finding ways to homeschool
kids that have been pulled out and
wanting to create like homeschool groups
and stuff and that's what a bunch of our
friends have started yeah you know like
and i think we're like pretty close
behind i'm just
i'm hoping we don't i think we're at the
best school in the island and i'm afraid
that if we pull it we can't get back in
oh really and um but you're more
inspired to home but i'm kind of like if
this garrett garrett's the one who wants
to be in hawaii like forever and i'm
like if this is a long-term play here
and if we pull
then i don't know what the long-term
plan is because i think we might need to
leave the island for a few years which
i'm open to but garrett's
he's in deep he loves yeah tell me what
do you what are your thoughts i mean
just at like a high level i've always
liked valued education over schooling
and so people think that i hate school
and like college and all that but i
don't like i love the social and there's
a lot of goodness that can come from
school but most of that goodness
is currently not happening due to covid
and so like if if you're not getting
that then like why school you know if
you're if you're just wanting education
well you can get that a lot of different
ways and so just with the current state
of things i don't think school is in an
awesome place and so until then yeah my
vote is i do love how i think there's
been a handful of times when we've
talked about the fischer's your family
when we're like man like everybody's
lives was flipped upside down except for
the first suspicions
our library
you know work for home home school from
home you know yeah our life did not
change that much but so many kids and
families have suffered and are still
suffering because they there might be
families who feel the same way as you
and they aren't able to pull their kids
out of school and i just feel so much
for that because you really want your
kids to be able to be in a place that
you're proud of that you really believe
is going to be best for their growth and
i know there's so many amazing teachers
that are doing their best and like
there's just so many struggles right now
it's really tough it's so tough and this
school like they're really just doing
the best they can but when you have
voices from everywhere and you're trying
to please everyone like it just turns
into a mess unfortunately it's really
sad perhaps you guys though i think that
speaks a lot that your your lifestyle
wasn't
influenced that much by like these
outside forces you know i think that's a
cool thing but yeah
thank you yeah i feel like it's kind of
like like for us our goal has always
been to like get more closer to like
nature natural living growing our own
food and stuff and it is a little bit of
a testament to be like okay so what
would happen if things got crazy
you know
but i i mean i don't know how much on
your podcast or to your own like
community you've expressed that's
probably not because you guys are humble
people but one thing i think worth
sharing is
how much in our community and our group
of friends that you guys are just this
like
source of just like information and
knowledge and and the way that you guys
share it is always very like friendly
where you're never like
you know
now in today's world there's a lot of
like i don't know if you'd even call it
bullying of people like putting pressure
on like hey this is how you should think
this is how you should live um i've
always been grateful how you guys are
constantly like sharing information but
it's not in like an overpowering way
it's like hey this is where we've found
some like health and joy and goodness in
our life and we want to like share it
with you um anyways it's cool how you
guys have become that voice and not just
our friends group but like the community
have you noticed that like
over the last year more people are kind
of turning to you for like the expertise
because you guys have been living this
way
yeah for a while now i don't know i
don't know if i've really noticed it but
i mean i just wonder if more people are
like like looking up the homeschooling
situation oh for sure like for sure as
well and just growing your own food
being like oh wow maybe we should be
doing that sort of thing right yeah for
sure and that's so nice thank you so
much a lot of people actually
assume that maybe like all my friends
are vegan or plant-based how do you get
how do you get all your friends to all
the same opinions as you was like no
that's not what friendship is like no
for me friendship is not about like us
all aligning on everything like it's
about like finding common ground being
open to each other's perspectives and
like respecting each other like
everyone's coming from a good place and
doing what they feel is best see that i
think that's cool that's what i was
trying to say because i think on the
online community you can definitely have
like a niche demographic but like in the
real world you've done a cool job of
like the being the source of information
in the community like offline and social
media all aside oh that's so nice thank
you uh i was surfing this morning and
people were talking about your podcast
out on the surf no way yeah it was cool
they were having like a conversation
about it i hadn't like watched it yet
and so it was fun to hear their like
perspectives on it that's awesome um i
don't even know how the people were but
they were talking about it really not
even brett brett wasn't out there well
he was out there with me but it was like
two other people that were chatting
about it oh that's so cool yeah i'm
really happy with that episode and i
love that i'm doing this one now
something i want to channel and change
shift into in this episode is like
is there anything and advice you have
any advice you have for people that
might like maybe didn't come from the
situation that you did and maybe they're
inspired and they're like i really want
to create something i want to live a
life with purpose i want to be
successful whatever success is for them
um but obviously different and maybe
they come from a different background or
socioeconomic
circumstance like what advice do you
have for those people well i think it
always just comes down to those
intentions right like if you're
i want to do instagram because i want to
travel for free and i want to have a lot
of followers like that's when you're
like no you should but if you're like i
just want to be with my family and i
want to document it and remember it
forever then it's like we'll go and do
it and like worst case scenario if
nobody ever watches your video or ever
sees your post
you had a great time with your family
like it doesn't matter so when we're
like trying to encourage people to do
stuff it really just
you know it's like if you have those
pure intentions
then it's never a waste of time
yeah that's a good advice because i'm
sure you're the same way that if
somebody comes with the intentions of
like hey i want a successful youtube
channel or i want a lot of followers on
instagram it's like
i don't know how to give you advice it's
really tricky oh i have no advice for it
like well and like you said like we
our timing was impeccable and your
timing was impactful you just put out of
it you didn't even realize that a
hundred thousand views was like a lot
you were just kind of like
there's my video yeah exactly um you
know so when you go into just being like
i want to document my life i want to
share some goodness with the world then
like everybody wins even if you're you
know it's gonna be so what about for
those who like maybe they have a
different dream and they're not trying
to be like online or anything but they
just want to be successful and like
doing what they love but maybe they feel
really stuck like they're like i can't
get out of this hard place that i'm in
you know like what what how do we move
forward from there to help people like
that or how do they help themselves
you go just
a little bit about us so jess hates it
when i
how do you say it when i give advice to
other people the amount of people who
have dropped out of school um change
their religion
uh job garrett brothers like so i
decided to leave our church because of
what you said and gareth's like what
turns out i say a lot of just things off
the top of my head people really take to
heart garrett's advice and even
you know heather they left and you know
her husband was like well you know gary
and i sat down for lunch and
heather was like yeah now he wants to
travel around the world what did you say
and i was like i don't remember we were
just having lunch together
that's the effect you have if i were to
try to defend myself it would be um
i
see myself as like an average human
and i was able to accomplish like my
dreams and so i think i do have a
gift that i can see people's like
highest potential inside them and so
when i sit down or i'm chatting with
someone i'm like oh i see the world in
you so i want the world for you and so i
encourage them and like hey go chase
your dreams like go for it if you could
see yourself the way that i see you you
would you would just go for it and so i
think that's why um i might have that
effect sometimes on people
um but it is the truth it's just i've
like felt just the fullness of joy from
pursuing my passions and dreams and why
would i not want that for everyone
totally that's beautiful because i think
a lot of people they might want to do
something but they're scared or they
don't have like support or anyone being
like their cheerleader like
and they're like i'm afraid to just step
out and take a risk and just do
something different even yeah or just
feeling stuck right but like drive and
purpose is is huge because not everybody
has the same drive well even for me who
is like you know the queen of moderation
and i
hate how much gear pushes me outside my
comfort zone like i'm the first one to
admit that like
i'm thriving in a life that i never
pictured you know what i mean like i
never thought i would love living out of
a suitcase and now i've turned into this
like minimalistic person who i can't
imagine any other way you know and so
sometimes when you
you know just thinking differently and
putting yourself into a situation like
when we came back from four months of
travel that we had initially set off
we looked at each other and we're like
okay like let's start the next business
and then we both were like but are we
liking this are we not and like we were
both surprised i mean especially me to
be like i'm really enjoying this and i
want to keep traveling and i'm good at
it and like
it's it's been a life that i'm living
that's completely different like i said
than i would have ever imagined
but i'm grateful for it i think it also
comes to being open to to the
possibilities of what might come to your
uh availability yeah
you know because an opportunity might
come your way there's a book that that
children's book that's like what do you
do with a chance have you ever seen that
book and it talks about how like i had
that first chance and i did it i didn't
take it and then they started coming
less and less because i just stopped
taking the chances and then it was like
then what i decided one day if i get
another chance again i'm gonna grab it
take hold of it and it was like the
biggest chance they ever saw and then he
like soars it's a really cute well and
if there's one thing that we can all
probably have in common from this last
year is just the
inconsistency and like stuff is not what
you expected
but if you kind of look at it
and try to change it and do something
you know
i think a lot of new possibilities have
been presented to each and every one of
us over the last year and a half and
you've had to like
redo the way you do things and rethink
the way you do things um and i think
it's okay like i've i've learned how to
let go
to plans and that's something i think
that's really important that everybody
kind of does you have to let go of like
preconceived notions and plans and how
you thought about things different you
know before and just being open to new
possibilities um because a lot of good
can come from it you know
totally
garrett you have anything to say to that
yeah my mind's like raising yeah
oh he's thinking he's gonna get in the
garden be like i told you
i just what she said about how
especially like covet and pandemic and
everything really like shook everyone's
lives i mean to an
optimist and entrepreneur all you just
see is end this opportunity
so that was
for sure have you guys ever seen the
documentary fire it's called like the
it's an acronym and it's like financial
independence retire early it's a really
good oh you have seen it i've heard of i
think i've heard you talk about it right
yeah our friend did a screening for it
quinn yeah okay um and a bunch of people
showed up it was so cool and it's such
an inspiring documentary because it it
shows real people with all different
kinds of backgrounds and circumstances
deciding like i'm i am in control of my
fate and my like the rest of my future
and i'm gonna do something about it and
it could take step by step by what
people do to like make short-term
sacrifices for like long-term gains and
it's incredible what people can
accomplish with
like just a bait like an understanding
on how to get there right and that yes
there will be sacrifices and
that's sometimes good because you
experience that and then you really
appreciate it down the road when you get
all that
sex with us anyways
um
why do you think you're as ambitious
that you are as you are
so i
have been deep diving into enneagrams
since i tore my acl thank you let's talk
about it right garrett's like i'm
leaving
no i think garrett is just at seven
through and through he's never content
seven you don't think you're a three no
no because he does stuff for freedom not
for success no wait you're shaking your
head he doesn't want to be put in a box
he calls himself divergent i'm like
right andrew's like what's the enneagram
that doesn't care about enneagrams
that's the number i am
well because i was like you know i've
been deep diving and i was like you're
an average seven oh that just made him
so mad
he's like i'm average nothing and then i
learned that there's a healthy seven i
would rather be an unhealthier seven
than an average
but garrett he i mean he's he's never
for the good and for the bad he's never
content with complacency
which as a nine is like the name of the
game for me it's like status quo right
and so it's this constant like he always
is going to be reaching for more wanting
more what's next what's next
i think it's kind of like a drug where
you
you put in hard work
and you feel the same fear that everyone
fear or feels and experiences when they
step outside their comfort zone and then
you taste the reward
it tastes good you want more for people
who don't know what the enneagram is
look it up how do you spell e-n-n-e-a-g
and so a nine would be like what's it
called a piece maker seven adventurist i
thought an enthusiastic enthusiast i
thought maybe you would be a three which
is the achiever yeah no no i mean
because i can see where you think that
because he is like an achiever and super
competitive right it comes down to your
motivation to your core motivation right
now that does stuff not to achieve but
for
the person to live life to live life yes
that makes sense you're not doing it for
like the money person you're doing it
for just your own in purpose inside
which makes me and the elena awesome
seven and ellen is
like wrote the chapter on eights i am
one thousand percent and eight and
that's why i'm like i am made for
podcasting you guys you totally are i'm
so made for this and even though i
haven't done any like challenging type
of um discussions with opposing views
yet i'm working on it and it's not going
to be the entire um podcast but every
once in a while i want to sprinkle in an
episode which is just like funny because
that's like what you thrive on is this
like discussion and debate and that's
what makes me like crawl into a hole oh
my god i have this theory okay let me
know i i don't mean this in a bad way
but i actually don't think a nine is a
peacemaker i think nines are avoiders i
feel like it's more like avoiding
conflict as opposed to bringing people
together i think there's different kinds
of nines right okay so it's like a
healthy nine that brings people together
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah that's so
interesting and nines are so good about
seeing everybody's like everybody's view
right like you you understand and which
also makes you kind of less opinionated
because literally you see all the sides
yes so it comes across as if you don't
have an opinion so it comes across but
yeah you just and that's literally how
it is with like politics today
like i see both sides right right is
there a number that's the most
opinionated
i think the eight eights and ones eights
yes eight the thing is though with me i
actually think i
the beauty about me right i'm just
kidding
positive about myself but um what i like
about myself something i like about
myself is that i love to be challenged i
love to hear other perspectives
obviously only with people who want to
engage in the discussion who are
enjoying it and who aren't like like if
i start engaging with someone who's like
a nine that's like i don't want to talk
about this like that's not fun i want to
talk to someone who enjoys discussion
who wants to hear all sides and go back
and forth and at the end of the day
something that i really like is that i
am i'm pretty good at bringing people
together and like finding common ground
and being like okay so where do we agree
where do we disagree how can we like
just understand why we think the way
that we do yeah and that's like my core
foundation that's like my
my number one hard school is like
bringing people together and where can
we find common ground and how can we
understand each other better totally
that's my number one goal probably in
life
i've realized over the years maybe not
number one but it's pretty high yeah
so do you guys ever get burned out like
from all that you do and how do you or
how do you prevent burnout
we're we're almost there
yeah constantly i'm sure especially you
and i on the creative side of things
because when you care too much about
something you're just constantly like
knocking on the door of burnout um
i'm not quite there yet but i can feel
it like around the corner and i'm
trying my best to like avoid it i think
you can use that too much like working
with your spouse we've really had to
learn what each other's like triggers
are and where they find stress and where
they don't so like there are times where
i can tell garrett's on the verge where
he can tell i'm on the verge so we've
had to just over the last literally like
six years had to like step in and kind
of carry some extra weight when we see
someone is like
you know struggling so we um currently
our focus is
majority of it is on our instagram and
our youtube but we're shifting right now
we started a company called the bucket
list studios and our hope is to create a
cartoon and
at the very beginning go back to like
where this idea was born and it came
from kind of this topic of not wanting
to burn out and i'd say there's two main
drives to it one was thinking of our
children and what's best for them and
we're like okay we
if our kids are like hey we don't want
this social media we don't want this
fame we just want to turn it off then we
would respect it and we would turn it
off and so wanting to almost like
prepare for that moment totally we
decided to
in a way like transition this into a
cartoon where our hard work and the
story that we've created could live on
while we can just like back out and back
into the shadows and like live our
regular lives and so that that's like
that's where we're at but that's also
now we're in the like building of that
phase so we're trying to build that up
so we're
done we're like doubling up we're
exhausted right now right but it's
awesome i think garrett like as kind of
a serial entrepreneur like this is your
new i mean you know the same thing with
like youtube like you can get burnt out
and garrett's super burnt out
of the youtubes and the editing and
stuff like that so now
it's like where else can i like
yeah the hope the hope is that the
cartoon will pick up and i can like
peace out on the youtube and then that's
actually the whole level of my podcast
my brain is the exact same it wasn't the
thought process it's actually why i
started the podcast on a new channel the
main reason why i started a new channel
because i do want to you know eventually
phase out of it and have just the
podcast where my children aren't in it
and just preparing for that like you
said for sure and because the
alternative is burning out and then it's
just done you know totally so i co i do
fail you for sure and i also do i'm like
very aware of like i do want to have my
kids like less online as time goes on
and the podcast
i'm feeling so much purpose from it
being able to have these conversations
and then on top of it phasing them out
so that makes sense and as a result
you're like doubling down so what are
all the things you're doing now
so garrett is we've built a team
building he's built a team there's
tennis now starting we're the buffalo
studios studios they're starting all the
character development and what it's like
to look and feel oh as a creative it's
just like a playground right now because
we're yeah designing the look and feel
of it we're writing the story of like
the this and you're starting to develop
like merch and product and what like
it's going to be like a full like we
want it to be an online offline
experience it's going to be like a big
not just a show you know what i mean
like the last thing we want with
our instagram youtube and this show is
for it to just to be put people online
more like if anything all of our goal
with this is to take people off the line
you know like inspire people oh you'll
really appreciate this like as soon as
you see i'm really excited when it's
ready to show you even just like a
little bit of it because you'll see that
it's not like mindless kid entertainment
oh my gosh there's such a hole like that
you're feeling such a need right now i
can't even believe even when you like
feel the pace of the cartoon it's not
just like bam bam bam bam in your face
we were just talking about that because
we watched this new movie that came out
literally all the new movies are just
super neon super flash flash flash all
these like pink pow all like it's
incredible how fast it's like i'm just
like what is going on it feels like a
tick tock type thing but a whole movie
and then we watched to kill mockingbird
black and white film a few days later i
was like this is
so nice
you'll be really proud of what we're
trying to create because it's it's
exactly the opposite of what's currently
out there
and i think it'll throw a lot of people
off and like
but i think because i think people are
picturing one thing and it's going to be
something different because when you
hear a cartoon you think just like dumb
entertainment people like cartoon
characters i mean
it would be easy though to turn what
we've done into a dora the explorer type
of right thing yeah so how's that how's
it gonna be different from like a
grown-up daniel tiger or a grown-up
dorothy
it's it's as of now and the way we've
like written it out but we're trying to
be very open-minded and flexible the
beauty of creating something in today's
world is like does it live on netflix or
youtube or disney plus like we're very
open-minded in how we're creating this
the more important thing to us is how
can we take a create a very
meaningful story and then share it with
as many people around the world to like
better the world okay so there's a lot
of different ways to do that but as of
now we've written out this like arc of a
story that takes place across three
seasons
30 episodes total
and it's like you you watch it in order
you go on this journey rather than just
most cartoons that you can just tune in
watch one and then that's that you know
so to try to and something that's been
really important to us from the
beginning is that our audience our
current existing audience like every
sunday we get pictures and videos and
stories of people who sit down with
their kids and watch it as a family and
we want that to be the same which is
very tough to do to have a full family
demographic that will all sit down and
watch an animated
20-minute episode together like it's
really tough like we're we're really
going up against something to have to
try to create what we're looking for but
it's gonna be awesome we're gonna do it
i don't think there's anybody else out
there doing what you're doing now and
that's what makes you guys so successful
because you're really just pushing the
limits expanding the horizons figuring
out where is there a need where can we
put good into the world because honestly
it really bothers me how the shows the
options that my children have to watch
are so
most of them don't have a positive
purpose most of them have negative
purposes with um just t the habits that
you're teaching in life and it's
mindless like very very little of it it
was funny when we because initially we
didn't know are we doing this ourselves
are we gonna you know garrett shop this
around to all the big networks and we
would go into some of these meetings and
they're like okay this is great i get it
we're gonna have 48
seven minute
episodes and you're like huh yeah yeah
like and they kind of just started to
put you into these like
boxes and even netflix is like we have a
three to five group a five to seven
group you know and we're like sorry we
are
full family right
so a year ago i went and pitched all the
big networks and they like they fell in
love with it based just off of our idea
and pitch and we had offers from disney
plus and hbo max that it was really
tough decision but we ended up turning
down those offers because we're like no
if we want to create something like
really really pure we can't have these
like outside pressures so let us like
work on it on our own and then take that
to them and see if they now like it
maybe they will if they don't there's a
lot of different ways that we can like
share this with the world so that's
where we're at i cannot wait for it to
come out and i know it's going to be
insanely successful
we'll see when it comes out it's going
to be it's going to be a while but we're
like slow cooking it so that it's
exactly what we want it to be like that
in itself could be like an entire
full-time job plus i know and then on
top of it and we're still
traveling so but really though like how
do you how do you prevent the burnout
like for us we have our like routines
i'm like okay this is what we do to help
us so what do you guys do to help you
guys not to just get so burnt out from
everything in general and just wanting
to shut up i mean i think this is the
first time in our lives where i mean in
the last six years i should say where
we're hiring a team where we're like we
have to find
really amazing people to like help us
build this and we've started and we have
some amazing people already
that see the vision and are so stoked on
it and
um and it's tough it's tough working for
us the fact that we'll like be in africa
on a completely different time zone and
have like 30 minutes on like sketchy
internet connection they're like alright
guys here's everything you got to do
next week we're going to have internet
connection again in 10 days we'll check
in you know so prop stories we're not
easy to work really good job so far
but also
okay so
for me thinking of burnout um it's like
right there around the corner for me but
also i've just found to like uh
just i like i enjoy that feeling of
being exhausted doing something you
actually love and care about rather than
like anyone who's had a nine to five
that they don't care about and they're
exhausted but for a different reason
like you're either gonna be tired or
exhausted either way you might as well
do it like something you really care
about um and so
yeah we feel like close to burnout but
we're like super grateful for what we do
you're right there is a difference
between being burnt out from something
you're not enjoying and it's like kind
of sucking your soul a little bit
versus you know which is we all and
having have those jobs in the beginning
right some of us had some of us have
those jobs for their life and there's
certain jobs that maybe i mean this
literally i feel like motherhood
right
wait you can really get burnt out of
like
it's repetitive right so you have to
find those ways to not get burned out
even just
from the daily from the daily routine
you know you know i think it's a good
sign of it is like i'll go to sleep just
so painfully exhausted but i wake up
like excited to like get back to work
when snapchat bought my app i went and i
worked for snapchat and it was and just
i was excited for a new opportunity i
had never had like a real job before at
that point and i was in here i was like
whoa director so you never have actually
done the the like the working at a
coffee shop
this was my first time and i was excited
like it felt like the first day of
school when i was going and um
very quickly like there's no better way
to say than i just felt my soul being
like sucked out of me it was so gross
like i remember for the first time in my
life i cared more what like my boss
thought of me than what i thought of
myself which is such a twisted gross
toxic feeling right and then and so many
different things about it where i was
like holy cow and then going back to
like i would wake up not excited
to go to work or to like live my day
and so really quickly i was like jess i
think i need to quit snapchat and she's
like uh it's been a month
i've been through three months and uh
and it was difficult because i couldn't
give her like a solid answer as to this
is why i need to quit but fortunately
for me like jessica knows me better than
anyone else and like understood that
underlying like what's going on here and
supported my like weird decision to
leave such a great job well i think it's
partly your personality too because some
personalities do strive at a simple job
my um oh actually it's not simple my
sister's husband who's amazing he's a
structural engineer and he loves his job
it's a nine-to-five job but he really
loves it and
personalities really are different some
people really like that um consistency
and don't have i mean that's how my dad
was like my dad and he's worked with
save company for the last 25 years nine
to five and so when garrett went to
snapchat i was live i'm stoked i was
like
he's gonna come home he's gonna turn off
his laptop at 5 p.m and he's going to be
like present
and garrett i mean he's always thinking
of the next thing so like most nights
you know like we're doing all our family
stuff but garrett's still got to be
checking this doing this and filming
that you know but that's just what he
loves right so
you know and and i
for me like my happiness comes from his
happiness
for the good god well that's that's a
start of a great or a foundation of a
great relationship is helping each other
love love what you do and love your life
for sure do you guys ever do like we
sometimes do like a no screen family day
where we'll just like put it all away
like no screens at all and we'll just
like hang out together and that always
is like a really good refresher to be
like look mom's not going to be on like
doing her work at all i love that and
also i think something that was
conscious for me like okay my dad is
such a great dad he has shown me love my
entire life i've always felt loved for
my dad because words of affirmation is
kind of like my love language and he's
always just been so great with that one
thing i did notice though growing up is
that he had a blackberry i don't i
probably have told him this but he had a
blackberry before smartphones were out
and i always noticed that like you know
when we would be at the dinner table
he'd be looking at his blackberry or if
i like talk to him maybe not like
looking up right away and like that that
did something to me and so i feel like
now i'm like very aware of like
if i'm working even if i'm working and
i'm hustling like if my kids come up to
me and they want to talk to me like put
it down and look them in the eye and
this applies to anyone even if your job
isn't about anything online like how
easy it is to just get on your phone so
much whereas
and to just get sucked into it you know
and that's another thing with the kid
thing it's like it's addicting for
adults let alone kids so i'm on a screen
and then kids your children come up to
you and want to say something to you
like
not even taking more than a second to
like put it down and look them in the
eye you know like that i feel like is
really
important
so i have a couple more questions that
are like simple questions that you
probably get asked all the time but i
still find them fascinating what is your
favorite place you've ever traveled to
mine is new zealand i love new zealand
it's just so beautiful people there so
active and outdoors like everywhere you
turn it's just a post caught it postcard
it's like it's just we could live it's
another planet
i would move there in heartbeat uh and
then mine uh is most any island anywhere
in the world
which is why we live here but also i
mean specifically uh in tanzania there's
an island zanzibar
it's a very special place that sounds
really good baby sea turtles dolphins
crystal clear water it's oh it's got it
all amazing i haven't been to very many
places in the world andrew and i've only
been out of the country i've i've been
to like a handful of countries out of
the world but i have been to bhutan
which is really random and different and
i remember i remember when you guys were
gonna go then i was like i've been there
that's like one of those random
countries
people have been to right i could be
like look guys i've been there just
because i haven't been to like near
anywhere that you've been that's awesome
but i've been to bhutan and that it was
beautiful yeah such an amazing festival
is a very special place the culture
there everyone is so kind that it's just
so pristine it's amazing and they how
they've
kept it so pure right at least when i
had gone nobody else has done that right
like at least when i had gone they had
only recent recently opened up the
country and it cost 100 a day just to
get into the country and they um didn't
have any imports from or at least i was
as far as i was aware which was
incredible like just so different and
great and crazy so the other thing is
what is the scariest thing you've
experienced any like really scary things
you've experienced on the road what was
it just recently traveling happened it
was very scary
um
we had a situation in mexico where we
were on a surf trip and it was
uh us and our friends and all the little
kids on board and i mean
we went out and very quickly went from
like a pretty nice day to just crazy
lightning storm and then the clouds came
in so far we were on this like metal
boat pitch black stormy waves lightning
storm all around two hours from land we
was crazy we thought we were gonna die
like all of us not the kids the kids
were like totally oblivious but like the
parents were like kind of like in their
minds like baby callie in one picture
like a surfboard in the other room
yeah
where are we going to swim that was very
scary
yeah it was one of those like
this is going to happen
yeah how's garrett's going to grab cali
with the surfboard i'm going to do that
like it was yeah like it's not like it
was just you guys on the boat was your
children as well yeah and then we we
made it back safe to cellulita and our
friends um sarah and ryan williams that
was on the west side they uh we all got
off and we were just like looking at
each other like
hugging like we're alive like i can't
believe we're up we had we had one scary
very like eye-opening situation though
where we were traveling to turkey this
was three years ago and well while we
were on our flight the u.s put out this
like
red alert like do not travel they were
evacuating like embassy
us nbc people explaining that isis had
like uh threatened any westerners they
come across in that region and so we
land in turkey to both of our parents
just like freaking out being like you
got to get out of turkey it was really
scary and there wasn't a
flight or an opportunity for us to leave
until the next day so we had to spend at
least one night there and we'd happen to
stay be staying in this like cave of a
hotel type place
and
we went to bed just very nervous like
holy cow
um like uh again picturing the worst
case scenario of like who's gonna get
taken how are they gonna take it how are
we gonna say i think that was the very
first time we had just like such a clear
lesson of like you can't always trust
like for your first impression of the
people or culture or what the media is
saying because if you were to ask us now
like hey where do you find the absolute
nicest people in the world
turkey like such wonderful kind
welcoming people and so we stayed there
we woke up the next morning and like 24
hours later i'm like jess i feel
wonderfully safe here like what do you
think of staying we ended up staying the
entire time no way and uh it was one of
our favorite places absolutely i love
turkey great lesson for us um i love it
there and i would recommend to like if
you go like have a guide who like
obviously knows where you're going but
like we would be in the grand bazaar and
you would see these i mean people who
like by stereotype might look scary yeah
by like media standards like literally
looks like a terrorist and they kind of
come up to your kids and turkish people
love children and they would come down
they would pull out a balloon in their
pocket and make a toy for the kids like
they were over the top
so in love with children and so kind and
like people you would come in and you
would try foods and they'd be like here
take this like and they weren't like
pushy salesy kind of like you can
sometimes get in india they were just
like yeah just take it like just the cut
literally the kindest people give you
the back the shirt off their back and
like and that's always been a lesson for
us like obviously
be a mindful traveler and be safe but at
the same time like
you can't judge a book by its cover
i mean it makes me think about when we
were talking about education for your
children how you literally do like world
schooling like they get so
much amazing like education just from
all that you do and travel with and all
that you guys have learned from people
and cultures so
i okay i also want to ask you like what
is like the coolest service work you've
ever done
um
it's tough like
it's like the best and the worst thing
that we've ever experienced is when we
went to nepal and we worked with a
non-profit called effect.org um in the
battle against human trafficking uh they
kind of explained to us look you're
gonna come here you're gonna see some
things you perhaps didn't even know
existed in this world it's like the
darkest side of mankind
and it's gonna be really hard on you for
the first day or so and then once it
kind of like settles in then we can like
get to work and start to like well and
the whole like thing too they brought
out a bunch of people from silicon
valley so there's a bunch of like
marketing
i.t people tech people and so what we
would do at the end is we would have
this like two day hackathon to like
create something like literally to like
take what we learned and then create a
tool to like help
and
we we struggled we couldn't just like
couldn't get over that hump of like okay
we've seen the darkest and now let's try
to like get out of there and be
productive like it just like the first
step is always anger and we like never
got out of the anchor step
you know what i mean like because you
kind of feel helpless a lot of times and
we brought our kids there so like to be
there with our daughter dorothy and yeah
like
we like working with this organization
and they challenged us to raise twenty
five thousand dollars to no 50 000 50
000
schools and and um because education is
the number one percent prevention in
human trafficking right at that time we
had like i don't know like 80 000
followers on instagram and i was like
guys how are we gonna raise fifty
thousand dollars when like i can't get
like 500 likes on a photo like oh this
is the numbers aren't gonna work out
here i'm sorry but they challenged us
and i was like oh shoot like well let's
at least give it a go it's a it's a good
yeah to be working towards and it props
to our audience like they came through
and within a month we raised the full
fifty thousand dollars is awesome that's
amazing it was really special and then
you know two years later we went to
india and we visited our school and it's
beautiful and so cute and just in like a
really poor area but like the cutest
little kids just doing yoga in the
mornings and like wow that's so
rewarding
because we actually our favorite um like
non-profit is uh charity water do you
guys have charity water and we did like
a fundraiser type thing with audience
and i found that like your audience like
rallies behind you you have a cause to
really support like your audiences are
amazing and i think i mean props to gary
he garrett's a really great story teller
in all of our videos and i mean i think
he really effectively like we told the
story remember the first time we
recorded our vlog though we literally
just sobbed through it
so we couldn't use it you started to
edit it and you're like this is not
gonna work i love how vulnerable you
guys are though you guys cry like every
other episode i feel like i don't i feel
like i might have cried online maybe
like once like it's mad problems
vulnerable no i cry a lot but i don't
know especially in our like buddhist
friends videos like literally yesterday
yeah and i'm like oh me too buckler's
friend i mean not my backlash friends
but my membership would you guys they're
the ones who inspired me you guys are
the ones who inspired me to start my
membership and i love my membership
um yeah that is incredible i think that
audience is really rally behind when you
support a cause and that's so cool yeah
so i have my last question for you guys
do you guys think that social media has
kind of hit its reach and there's like a
bubble being like the entrepreneurial
side and like you have so much you have
so much insight behind these things you
talk to so many really successful people
and you just kind of like you amaze me
when i come to you with like questions
and stuff you have all these ideas and
oh that's interesting that you i've
never even thought of it that way so
what are your thoughts on social media
and how it's just become super
oversaturated and is the bubble gonna
break what's the future going to look
like in your mind
so i do think social media is greatly
broken
it
um
for example i spoke with someone who
works at instagram and facebook and i
remember telling them like how much does
it bug you that people will talk about
like the golden days of instagram or the
golden days of facebook and how much
it's just broken now and how they hate
the algorithm and they wish they could
go back to like a chronological feed and
i was like venting all the things that
like everyone vents about i'm just
wanting like a
social media platform in its purest form
and
i should like this person is like high
enough at facebook they like make the
decision they like control what facebook
is becoming and when i heard them say
they go people
think they don't like what instagram is
becoming but if you saw the numbers it
proves that people actually do like it
more because they're spending more time
in an app
and when i heard this person who
determines what facebook is becoming
say it that way it broke my heart
because i was like nah you think
like they're making their decisions
based off of analytics and numbers and
i'm like there's a very different
experience between someone opening the
app enjoying it for five minutes and
then turning it off experience feeling
fulfilled yeah and going on versus
someone just getting in this like rabbit
hole that they like experience unhealthy
for like 20 minutes and all of a sudden
they're like what happened to me they
turn it off and they feel gross right
instagram wants the second time yes
because that's where they make more
money yeah it's all about the money you
know and so if you only make your
decisions based off the numbers you're
going to choose that second scenario and
so for that reason i think social media
is just like it's a broken thing and so
the good news the silver lining here is
uh it's up to the individual how much
they let it be toxic and negative and
versus who they follow how they use it
the information or the content that they
create and put out there and so you
can't complain about it too much because
at the end of the day it's like up to
you
that's really impactful i think because
i i totally agree it's totally up to the
individual and how you form and shape
what you look into and what you're
paying attention to and absorbing and i
think that that is definitely the way to
go we can't really expect these
companies who are you know about profit
and about how to grow it and how to get
as many people online as possible
who are taking advantage of our
weaknesses right
right and we can't really blame them but
at the end of the day it's up to us
i think that's a great way to end it
thank you guys so much for coming on the
show and sharing your story like you
guys are so inspiring and impact so many
people every day and i'm just so
thankful you came on yeah thank you well
congrats this is amazing thank you happy
for you thank you all right bye
[Music]
you